the
there's something about famine
you know that um
is another is another level of
evil to me you know what
stalin did in ukraine in the 30s yeah
[ __ ] him yeah
this is what torture is cannibalism
yeah and um north korea too
they humans right now in 21st century
7 billion people on this earth right now
you make the
enough food for 10 billion people nobody
should starving right now it's worrisome
to me
the humanity is moving forward with
technological advances blah blah we are
going so
fast in in advancement and we are
leaving this like 25 million
human beings in the cage completely
leaving them behind
and north korea is living like 16
centuries i never like this morning i
was taking a shower
beautiful shower like one never knew
what shower was
i was bathing few few times a year going
to the
like river how do i even know what
shampoo is
and this is how human beings in 20
persons living
and it doesn't bother us and rather most
people obsess being a vegan
and like how how do you reconcile
this i think we get used to stuff very
quickly we get used to comforts that's
just the way of human life you
you take the beautiful things for
granted
so i try to appreciate everything i have
so whether it's
uh like the food i have now or like the
luxury to have a diet and
be struggling with that yeah or just the
basic simple moments of being alive with
the people i love but actually i get
like
i think i'm on drugs all the time
because i feel like just even like
uh this mug everything on this table
just brings me joy
but it's like filling your life with joy
in the full capitalistic american way
you can still
at the same time uh not feel too bad
about yourself
no and still focus on the the suffering
in the world
and i think there's some way
that in trying to build a better world
in america it has ripple effects
elsewhere sort of like so i'm a fan of
rockets in space it sounds perhaps
counter-intuitive but sending raucous to
space
will help solve the north korea uh
a problem because it lets
people dream yeah and build
cool stuff so it's not the rocket it's
the other people
that like are inspired by the rocket and
then look to
other problems in the world i mean
that's what elon did is like he saw
problems in the world and saw like what
can i do to help it
and i think the north korea one is a
tough one though
because that's ultimately has to do
with revolutionizing government
china china that's what it takes
changing chinese communist party is
impossible
that's why we couldn't solve north korea
for that many decades but
it's china well for now it's china but
it's china
it's um so it's uh
russia it's certain aspects of the
united states and struggling with that
uh one of the you know there's a bunch
of technologies that are striving at
this
um for example uh i don't know what your
thoughts about cryptocurrencies i love
it
so like there's a idea that money
could be a way to destroy or to
challenge
the power centers of the world yeah so
if you give
if you take away the power from fiat
currency and give it to
this thing that can't be controlled by
government that's cryptocurrency whether
it's bitcoin ethereum all those kinds of
things
that's a way to get money into the hands
of people
to where the government can't take that
money away but north koreans don't have
electricity
no internet so yeah we can do that with
china
we can do it a lot of african
dictatorship countries right
i do think big cryptocurrency is such a
fascinating technology
right i think this is an amazing
experiment when
that power is in our hands i'm the huge
advocate believer
but i think nurse is too behind yeah you
know i think that's what is unique about
north korea is that
most of things that we talk about is now
it's different planet literally
the common law that we have is now
applicable
you